to the hour now president biden cracks a
joke but deflects questions about covid
when reporters press him over testing
problems and broken promises
health officials say most americans will
get
at some point
folks we'll talk about that later
maybe a press conference mr president we
look forward to that
me too
joe
is here to react joe
what did you make of the president's
speech yesterday and that answer from
the president about a press conference
par for the course what else can you say
the president has not had a formal press
conference in more than 10 weeks and
when you think about everything that's
happened carly todd as far as build back
better and the push around that
trillions in new spending when you think
about vaccine mandates when you think
about all this push around voting rights
you would think in a normal presidency
that the president would try to sell
that as much as possible and that would
include taking questions from the press
at least the ones that aren't
hand-picked and instead he's hiding
behind his press secretary skirt at this
point and by the way unless i missed it
did any of the late night hosts give
biden the trump treatment on the current
president not even knowing who was
tapped to be his testings are because
you get the feeling he's never heard of
the guy before and i believe that joke
writes itself
i believe we have that clip listen ah to
help uh lead our federal testing program
i've talked i've i've taught i've
excused me i've tapped uh dr tom
i hope i pronounced it and angel
angles me
correct is that right jeff
joe how bad is that
that that is so bad i mean again just
just picture if donald trump had tapped
a testing czar at the height of a
pandemic when cases are higher than they
ever have been and he can't even
remember the person's name obviously
that person was tapped for this
president and as far as not taking
questions again this is the most guarded
protected scripted president of our
lifetimes you'll find liz cheney at
mar-a-lago before you see joe biden sit
down for an in-depth interview with
anyone resembling a fair and tough
journalist let me break it down for you
one more time in a couple of seconds
he's done just 16 one-on-one interviews
since taking office at this stage of
trump's presidency he had done more than
70 interviews four times more we'll
leave it there
yeah a really tough press conference for
um or i guess a speech for president
biden because he didn't take questions
in a really tough interview for the vice
president as well yesterday
meanwhile
mitt romney was critical of the
president's speech on election reform
and then white house press secretary
jenn saki responded to that criticism
it's getting a lot of attention take a
listen to this
i expected more
of president biden
who came into office
with the stated goal
of bringing the country together i know
there has been a lot of claim of the
offensive nature of the speech yesterday
which is
hilarious on many levels given how many
people sat silently over the last four
years for the former president
yeah but joe mitt romney who's far from
silent over his criticism of the former
president
yeah i believe he uh voted at least one
article of impeachment against donald
trump so to say that mitt romney has
been silent uh it's ridiculous right too
yeah that's right sorry thank you see we
like fact checks in the middle of this
and i apologize for the error uh yeah uh
look she also said that mr biden had
used quote objectively true statements
unquote on republicans trying to take
away a legitimate right to vote at least
that's what she claims look his speech
was widely panned including by members
of his own party he got four pinocchios
by the washington post about another
arrest that never happened during that
speech right look the president has had
the worst 72 hours of any you can
remember uh and here is the bottom line
his approvals clocked in at 33 percent
stacey abrams blew him off in florida
his voting rights push was thwarted by
members of his own party his vaccine
mandate for businesses was shot down by
the supreme court all the matter of two
or three days
nothing going right for the 46th
president guys
joe thank you so much for joining us
happy friday
oh happy friday and happy
happy this guy this is the uh
baby shark that i talked to rachel
campos duffy about last night apparently
it's the most viewed youtube clip of all
time we always leave it on a happy
billion views
10 billion views we did a billion of
them yesterday joe gotta go i'm steve
ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm ainsley
earhart and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis